6 14 it's Tuesday Morning organizers
call it Sherry the American Idol of
ballet this week auditions are taking
place in the valley for youth America
Grand Prix now it's the world's largest
Dance Network an aspiring performers
compete for scholarships so it's pretty
competitive and joining us live to talk
about it is Quinn Callahan artistic
director of Rock Center for Dance on
Maryland near Windmill and good morning
Quinn thank you for being with us I I
first want to ask you these girls are
lovely and accomplished and they're
competing for scholarship money that's
going to send them to some pretty
prestigious schools and dance companies
where will these scholarships take these
young ladies and dancers
well mostly they're competing to prepare
themselves for a future in the ballet
and contemporary dance career the
scholarships take them to many ballet
companies throughout the world
okay so which is very important of
course if they want to have a career in
this field to get to get started on this
you see the girl we can see the girls
dancing behind you here I assume this
isn't something that a child or their
kid can just go and audition for that
this takes years of practice even at a
young age
yes many years and many hours are
devoted to their training they do start
very young however but to get to this
stage yes they have to be quite
experienced
how many uh how many young ladies and
and possibly young men too will receive
dance scholarships throughout the days
of competition this weekend
well it's partly a competition
where they're rewarded
opportunities to be invited to the
finals so this is a semi-final so that's
part of the
um the that's part of the plan where
they go through the semi-final and then
they get invited to to the finals where
then they're offered Scholarships in the
National and international realm there's
several countries that have dancers
competing about 15 to 20 countries very
exciting stuff and you know for
young dancers who want to be and make
this their career right this is very
important stuff and the dances behind
you are just doing a beautiful job this
morning Quinn thank you for joining us
this morning for the Youth America Grand
Prix to talk about the auditions
happening in the valley uh coming up we
appreciate it thank you very much we
wish them a lot of love thank you thank
you so much it's going to be
nerve-wracking I'm sure